a moment of respite in Gaza the first
day in s weeks when people can feel
relatively safe a ceasefire that is
holding thousands waiting for a chance
to reunite with their loved
ones honestly it's a nice feeling for us
to be able to go back home after all
this time to see families and loved ones
but we are still hesitant and Afraid a
4- day truce is not enough those in the
north of Gaza were worried about them as
they did not head to their homes like we
did
here in the north of Gaza the stench of
death hangs heavy in the air many bodies
are still buried under the rubble the
non-stop Israeli attacks meant
paramedics and teams of volunteers were
unable to retrieve them the Gaza Health
Ministry estimates nearly 15,000
Palestinians have been killed many
families who stayed in the north went
back to their homes to find there's
nothing
left I came came to the N Tower District
in B hanon where we used to live to
check our home and collect the little
clothes I could find I need to pick up
also some bed covers and anything that
can protect us from the cold and the
rain because of the war and intense
bombardment we had to leave and move we
sought refuge in schools and today we
came back to see what's leftt of our
home the UN says more than 80% of gaza's
population has been displaced for those
forced to move South though there is no
option of
returning I really really wish that they
would let the residents of Gaza City to
go back I prefer living in my house to
be humiliated in my house is better than
being humiliated
here even if I went back home I fear
there could be another attack on the
area and I'll die I'll only go back
there once the war is over I don't trust
what Israel promises I don't have faith
in them not even for an hour I don't
believe in this
ceasefire the south is where Israel told
the residents of Northern Gaza to head
for their safety yet some parts of
Southern Gaza now look like this the
ceasefire offers a breath of fresh air
to more than 2 million people left with
very few options for survival even if
for only a few short days Demetri medeno
Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer